[Applause]
[Music]
luno the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
pen show as usual it is powered by the
vc firm icon plus capital and it is
sponsored by block five so right now
with block five you can get up to i
think it's around nine and a half
percent interest on your stable coins um
so pretty great i actually do use them i
really enjoy using them and um if you
want to sign up there's a link in the
description and in the comment section
so today we have a really exciting guest
we're going to talk about a really broad
range of topics so it is the macro
investor libertarian youtube host trad
fight expert and all-round extremely
knowledgeable individual it is george
gammon george welcome to the show thank
you for having me yeah there's a quite a
list of qualifications but one thing i'm
not good at is social media so hopefully
i got that tweet right
yeah no worries no worries we'll see how
that goes
but yeah it's good to have you we were
chatting earlier and i was saying that
i've been following a lot of your
content your youtube content but in
particular with everything that's going
on in the world right now
you have some very um insightful views
when it comes to
the lockdowns and the increased uh
government intervention that we've seen
so i want to talk about everything so
i'm really excited to have you but i
would really just like to pass it to you
actually and ask you what would you say
right now is the most important topic to
talk about i know that there's inflation
and we've spoken you've spoken a lot
about that on your youtube but what for
you right now is the most concerning
thing
well it doesn't matter how much bitcoin
you have gold silver real estate if you
ain't got freedom you got nothing
absolutely that sums it up if you're
locked up in a cage it doesn't matter
what your portfolio looks like
it doesn't matter how many dollars you
have in the bank and what people need to
realize is it's not just about freedom i
think that's priority number one
but it's also about understanding what
wealth is
and wealth has nothing to do with your
bank account
uh wealth has to do with how many goods
and services you have access to
and i always use myself as a good
example
my portfolio today
has a bigger number on it
than it did in 2019
but am i richer or am i poorer
well obviously when we look at the
standpoint of freedom i'm much much much
poorer but even if you look at it from a
standpoint of how many goods and
services i have access to i'm also poor
last time i went to whole foods
20 of the shelves are barren
so that means i can't buy that stuff
it's almost impossible to get a
reservation at a restaurant as an
example
it's uh i mean you go down the laundry
list of items that are no longer
available
and again it doesn't matter if your
portfolio is done well you are poorer
today than you were in 2019
and people really need to understand
that they need to open their eyes i
always use the example of a deserted
island right if you're there
with a chest full of a billion dollars
or a billion dollars worth of gold
or you've got your billion dollars with
a bitcoin
are you rich or are you poor
you're poor because there's no stuff
and this is what people need to realize
and you know there's this massive push
towards authoritarianism but there's
also a massive push to try to convince
people that they don't need to produce
that they can just sit there and float
through life
and they can speculate they can gamble
or now you know we're looking at what's
coming out with best buy nordstroms and
gaap uh now we're incentivizing say or
telling people that they not only have
to go to work but they can just steal
whatever they want because they're not
going to prosecute anyone that steals
a dollar amount under a thousand dollars
so it's this whole just bizarre
uh
push that we have in the united states
and in the western world uh and for as
far as freedom globally uh that i think
takes us to a very very dark place and
this is the road to serfdom uh if people
don't see that they're just not paying
attention to history
you know what really concerns me it's
the lack of outrage that we've seen so
in austria vaccines are now compulsory
so we don't know whether that means you
go to prison or whether you get a fine
or whatever that means if you know the
government takes if you don't allow the
government to have full say over what
happens to your body so why
you know if it's so obvious for you and
i but why do other people not see it
because all they do is pay attention to
bumper stickers on cnbc or excuse me cnn
and msnbc these bumper sticker slogans
what they're trying to do is they're
trying to take complex topics
and they're trying to understand them
with very very basic slogans that you
can fit onto a bumper sticker and
unfortunately
the cerveza sickness if you want to call
it that it doesn't work that way it's
it's like the weather it's like the
economy that it's incredibly complex
and to sit there and just say that uh
a medicine as an example is just quote
unquote good
or it's quote unquote safe what does
that even mean
you've got to define those terms
and i think you know i was listening to
some people in the mainstream media and
their arguments uh that they have
because i'm you know i always constantly
ask myself maybe i'm missing something
right and it and if it's the bottom line
is they're not doing any research
because you have these slogans that are
just repeated over and over and over and
over again in the mainstream media so
people that don't have the time to do
the research they just think they're
obviously true
uh when in reality they have nothing to
do with re uh with what is accurate and
they're just completely fiction they've
been made up to push a narrative that's
really the bottom line uh as an example
you know they're saying that uh
these
call them medicines uh reduce the rates
of transmission and that's just not true
if you look at the uh the viral load
it's the exact same with uh regardless
of what your medicine status is that now
you could say well it's a reduced
chance of getting this race sickness in
the first place uh well that's fine but
then you have to ask yourself if someone
does get the cerveza sickness and
they've chosen to take the medicine what
are the chances that they get
symptoms it's a lot lower that's the one
that's the defined benefit of the
medicines okay so if you have that same
viral load if you're out there walking
around going to work you're at the going
to the the house party you're going to
thanksgiving dinner you're doing all
these things going out to the mall you
don't even know you're sick you don't
even know that your viral load is so
high that you're most likely
transmitting that to other people
whereas if you have chosen not to get
the medicine then you're going to know
you're sick
and you're going to have symptoms so
this is the nuance that is required in
these types of debates that are
completely void uh in the mainstream
media and unfortunately um
you know
people just go along with it and i i
don't that's the part that i can't
understand why i think
we need to have some level of skepticism
especially when these institutions and
politicians have been lying to the
people from the get-go i mean how many
times does someone need to lie to you
until you become skeptical of what
they're saying
right i mean when fauci comes out says
oh mass don't work and two weeks later
oh masks work and then biden says in in
december 2020
we'll never have mandates in the united
states
and six months later you got mandates in
the united states he says oh we're never
going to need a boosters and he says oh
well actually you need boosters and they
say well why why did you lie well we had
to
because if we wouldn't have lied then
people would have done what we wanted
them to do
and they just come out and admit it
so i don't understand how someone as an
example the five-year-old child
can listen to an individual or an entity
that has lied to them over and over and
over and over and over again and now
tells you that a specific medicine
that
we really don't know the long-term
consequences is quote unquote safe for
your five-year-old how do they believe
them at this point in time
it's just it's absolutely staggering to
me but the good news is you're seeing a
lot of people really push back i just
did a story
about uh 600 employees at google that
signed a manifesto to the management
where they're pushing back against the
mandates and they're articulating their
position extremely extremely well
and i think that's another way that you
can determine who's kind of right or
who's wrong
on this topic is listen to the people
who are opposed to the mandates and
listen how well thought out their
argument is and how much data they have
and how many studies and facts they have
and then listen to the people
in the mainstream media that are just
telling you just to blindly
uh take this you know foreign substance
and inject it into your body regardless
of whether or not you have natural
immunity or regardless of whether or not
you're uh you're pregnant
or regardless of whether or not you're
you're five years old you know
listen to their arguments and you'll
notice how shallow they are
they're completely void of facts or data
at pretty much every level and i think
that's another way that you can easily
tell
uh you know who you should believe who
you shouldn't believe or at the very
least be skeptical of those individuals
and entities that are just um you know
espousing these bumper sticker slogans
with nothing to back them up
so the question then really is why
why are they lying why are they
mandating these things if you know you
brought up a really interesting point if
you're if you've had the medicine i like
the use of that word smart um if you've
had the medicine um and um you're going
about your day you can still pass it on
but obviously you'd have lower symptoms
and so that could be dangerous but if
you haven't had the medicine then you
would feel sick and you stay at home and
you wouldn't pass it on that's really
interesting that's a great piece of
nuance there that we're not talking
about so why why is that happening now
you have to also have had the medicine
to enter the united states and the land
of the free not so free so
it's it's it's getting worse like this
freedom is um they're really clamping
down on it um boosters just to say they
also spoke about in the uk um people
over 65 if they haven't had the booster
then maybe
they may not be able to um take part in
in certain parts of society so that
would be my parents unfortunately um so
why it's absurd
because they're trying to condition you
see it goes back to the psychological
study that i referenced a lot in my
videos it's called the foot through the
front door theory and what happened
these psychologists i believe they were
in california they went into this
neighborhood and they asked the first
group of people if they would put a
small sign
in their front yard i think it's
something to the effect of please slow
down
and the the group of those individuals
who said yes they kind of put them in a
bucket then they next went to another
group and they asked them to sign a
petition so something a little different
there was an ask there but it was
slightly different
uh and then they went to a third group
and they didn't ask them to do anything
for the first round
okay then they went back to those three
groups
and they said okay now what we'd like
you to do is put this giant sign
in your front yard saying pretty much
the same thing
so the group that they didn't ask
anything of to begin with
less than 20 percent said yes to the big
sign
the group that did that had
something they agreed uh to do but was
slightly different that was the petition
uh their rate of acceptance for the big
sign was about 55 percent
with the group that agreed to the small
sign
over 75 percent
of those people agreed to a big sign
see so what this tells us
is that just the way we're hardwired as
human beings
when you get us to agree to something
small the probability of us agreeing to
something bigger and bigger and bigger
in the future
uh increases
so you start off with well we'd like you
to wear these masks okay we'll do that
oh actually you know what we'd like you
to lock yourself in a cage and oh yeah
thanks for doing that but actually we
want you to shut down your your small
business
and oh actually you know now we need you
to wear five masks and oh yeah thanks
for doing that but now we need you to
inject this foreign substance into your
body and oh yeah you did that but now we
need you to do it to your kids as well
and you see my point there is that this
is a way to condition you to get you to
agree to things that you never ever
would have agreed on just
or agreed to do back in 2019 but the
problem here and especially for the
do-gooders who want to stick up for this
mandate the people who truly do believe
that it's still about health the problem
there is that once the cerveza sickness
is in the rearview mirror assuming we
get to that point
the power and the control that you give
to the government is not going to go
away
they're not going to give it back to you
that freedom and liberty they take away
you're not getting it back
you see but the pr but even if this
conditioning process was unintentional
it still sets society up
to be controlled to a greater degree
than they were before
and that is the the real problem here
when you're doing a thorough cost
benefit analysis as far as these these
mandates these policies the lockdowns uh
the mask mandates the the medicine
mandates you know just list whatever
policy you want to throw out there when
you're doing a thorough cost benefit
analysis you not only have to determine
what the dangers of the cerveza sickness
are you also have to determine what the
benefits
of the the medicine is
and people who do a cost benefit very
few do but the people who do a
cost-benefit analysis at least they do
those things but what they completely
omit which is the most important thing
is how dangerous is the government that
you are seeding that power and control
to how dangerous are they how big is
that government and what is the
probability that they use that power and
authority against you and your kids and
your grandkids decades into the future
you know one of the uh the supreme court
decisions that i reference a lot in my
videos
and people who are pro-mandate they
always bring this up as though it
somehow backs their position
and this was the the supreme court case
or decision in 1905 jacobson versus
massachusetts and this was regarding the
smallpox
medicine we'll call it and this was not
to force people to get it it was just
they had a simple fine if they didn't it
was five dollars the equivalent about
150 today
and so this jacobson fellow said no i'm
not going to do that so it went to the
supreme court the supreme court sided
with massachusetts so he had to pay the
five dollar fine
and so people reference that say well
there you go
there you go see the supreme court
already decided on this in 1905 so the
government should have the power to do
anything they want today
because back in 1905 they made that
decision you see but what they're not
or what they're omitting from the
argument most likely intentionally or
maybe they're just completely ignorant
is the supreme court decision in 1927
and this was buck versus bell
so the reason we got buck versus bell or
the the reason the decision was made is
they directly referenced the 1905
decision
so this set the precedence for what we
saw in 1927 buck versus buck versus bell
well you say well what was that decision
that's the decision in the united states
that legalized eugenics
okay that most people don't even know
that was part of american history
because we like to sweep it under the
rug
but 1927 the supreme court said that it
was legal
to force
sterilization
upon people in the name of eugenics
and the precedence they used for that
decision again was 1905.
so the cost-benefit analysis today that
we need to do is not just what's
happening
today or in the next six weeks or the
next six months but we need to ask
ourselves if we give the government this
type of control and power if we set this
precedence today
in 2021 what's it gonna look like in 20
years for our kids and grandkids that's
the question we really need to ask and
no one's doing it
i think that's such an important point
because i mean earlier you mentioned did
we not learn anything from history and
people often say
we have a great government they care
about us they're very nice what's the
problem particularly with the democrats
and and all of that so how would you put
it to somebody you know how would you
put it to someone and you would say what
do you mean you trust your government
how can you trust your government you
don't know who could be in power
tomorrow
how can you yeah
it's easy all you have to do is look at
the size of government
uh because there's a direct correlation
with the size of government
and how
psychotic the people that apply for
those positions are going to be
essentially or
the level to which they are a sociopath
because you think about it the larger
the government is the more control it
has over the economy and society and the
individuals in that society
so if you're someone who is a sociopath
well then you're you have a strong
desire and an insatiable lust
to have power over over other human
beings
and therefore you're going to do your
best
to become a politician
and you're going to do your best to work
your way
uh you know to steal to lie to do
anything that you need to do
which is basically how politicians win
uh you're not gonna have any moral
backbone you're not gonna have any
ethical north star whatsoever you're
going to crush whoever you need to crush
you're gonna say whatever you need to
say to get to the top because you have
that insatiable lust to control other
people
see you're psychotic
right now if we had a small government
like we did let's say back in the early
1800s
well then you would have people like
george washington
where you literally had to twist their
arm for years
to get them just to be the president of
the united states and they kept saying
no no i don't want to do that i just
want to go up to martha's vineyard i
want to be a farmer now i'd want to do
that
why because that attracted the right
people
when government is small and government
doesn't control the people or maybe
better said when the government is
afraid of the people
yeah instead of the people being afraid
of the government that's when it
attracts the people that you want to
have as politicians right when the when
the people are afraid of the government
when it has that much power and control
then you're gonna get people in there
that are these uh future dictators or
have the the propensity
to be a dictator and even if you say oh
george that's crazy talk oh that's never
gonna happen in the united states oh
really oh really well look what what is
happening right now in australia
where they're literally sending people
to quarantine camps
that not just have the survey sickness
but anyone that was in proximity
of those people and not in the entire
country to be fair but even if that's
happening in small territories what's
the next step you don't think that we're
on a slippery slope right there and see
the people will always push back and
they'll say oh george well that
reference to the 1930s in germany
that's just using uh you know hyperbole
that's just exaggerating that's just
going over the top that's ridiculous
give me your proof
why
see that's what those people can't do
they can't give you a reason why why is
australia not going to be germany in 5
or 10 years why
is the probability absolutely zero
no it's not
and i would argue they're getting closer
and closer and closer to that all in the
name of safety and freedom or safety and
security which by the way
was the exact same argument that they
used in the 1930s in germany
you know you know people forget that
that those germans that went along with
that campaign those the ordinary you
know average john jane these people were
not demons
these people were not immoral what they
were but they were persuaded because we
have this flaw as
in our hard wiring where we are easily
persuaded
to do something that
that
in another circumstance would seem
absolutely crazy
and we need to realize our vulnerability
to that and australia is a perfect
example
see so my point there is if you go back
to 2019 i would have told you that
they'd be sending people to
essentially prison camps
in uh us in australia in a year and a
half you would have told me that i was
out of my mind that i was i'd probably
believe the probability of that was
literally zero literally zero
so if we're seeing that today
well then
why can we not see something more
extreme in five years and why could we
not see something that looks like
germany in 10 years are the australians
somehow immune to it are they immune to
those same forces of persuasion that
took over the german public i don't
think so
so how far um
do you think this is going to go
well i think there's some reason to be
optimistic there uh because i i you know
i
go around the country i do a lot of uh
public speaking and i just did an rv
tour throughout texas and uh in tucson
arizona and i'm meeting people face to
face
and i believe that the people out there
that value
the sovereignty of the individual
that are that see this push towards
ether authoritarianism and are extremely
concerned and they want nothing to do
with it because they have studied
history
i believe that they're the silent
majority
and that makes me uh not only optimistic
but that puts a lot of wind in my sails
whenever i'm going whenever i'm having a
bad day or whenever i'm you know trying
to find the motivation to do six or
seven uh videos on the topic uh you know
monday through friday
on the rebel capitalist channel that uh
and you know
i'm a big fan of the second amendment
yep uh which is you know people's rights
to own firearms but i'm an even bigger
fan
of the ability to have
like-minded people come together
and practice civil disobedience i think
that's has even more power and uh the
example i use is phoenix that's where i
am right now a town of about four
million people so if you would have gone
back to the the lockdowns let's say in
march april of 2020 and you would have
had three or 400 guys that have gone out
to the streets uh that would have posed
the mandates with guns let's say they
would have been wiped out i mean
instantly by the military or the police
who knows what would have happened but
that would not have gone well
but
if all four million people
would have just said no we're not going
along with your lockdown i'm going to go
walk my dog i'm going to go to the gym
i'm going to go to my college i'm going
to go to the restaurant the small
business owners would have done the
exact same thing
and as a group they would have practiced
civil disobedience what could the
government have done
what would the police have done what
would the military nothing
absolutely nothing and another great
example is the berlin wall
yeah you know how did the berlin wall
come down was it that east germans just
went out there with a bunch of guns
no
it's just that you had a group go out
there that were that was fed up
that they got to the point a tipping
point
where they valued freedom and the
freedom of their kids and grandkids far
more than they valued their own safety
they went out to the wall
and then other people saw them do it
that silent majority and all of a sudden
the silent majority wasn't silent
anymore
and those people went out to the wall
pretty soon you've got these guards out
there with the guns but they're
surrounded by thousands and thousands
and thousands of people
and they know
darn well that if they use one of those
guns their life expectancy is about
three minutes
see so what do they do they drop their
guns and the people tore down the wall
and that was the end of communism
see it was from the
silent majority coming together and
practicing civil disobedience and i
think that that's uh something they did
back then very effective i think that's
something that we can do today that we
just as effective
so this kind of makes me want to go down
a little tangent um we don't have to go
too far down it i would be interested to
hear your opinion um so civil
disobedience um and you mentioned um in
phoenix
the picture that you kind of painted to
me was you know strong men going out
there leading the way
i don't really think of it as like as
women i think of it as strong
men yeah i use the example of men going
out there with the guns yes uh because i
just wanted to point out that even if
you got these strong guys out there that
are you know six feet tall 250 pounds if
they got it doesn't matter they're gonna
get wiped out
uh the
greater power uh is when women men
everyone stands together uh as a force
and practices the civil the civil
disobedience yeah
but
still on that point of men going out
there with the guns and so on and so on
i do believe that it would be men are
technically bigger than women men are
technically stronger than women
physically and i do sort of feel that it
would be men strong men that would lead
the way and fight communism like i'm
sure if we looked at the vernon wall the
ratio of men to women who actually were
able to pull that thing down would be
men
so
a lot of people often say that there's a
war on men right now like a war and
masculinity
um
there's like a lack of empowerment you
know the idea of toxic masculinity we
we're not allowed to see men be strong
and they're kind of trying to pull men
down to the level maybe physically where
women are at i wonder if you had any
thoughts on that and whether yeah i
don't want anyone to eat meat they just
want you to eat more and more soy
products
which will reduce the testosterone
levels
of uh the average male by even more than
it's been reduced i mean the average
testosterone level of a male in the
united states i don't know the exact
figures but it's dramatically lower
today than it was let's say in the 1950s
or the 1960s so if you're a dude and you
have low testosterone
that that does not bode well for your
ability to stand up and go out to the
berlin wall
i i can tell you not only your ability
but your willingness to do that
uh you know that usually comes from a
significant amount of testosterone
so i think that could be and i don't
have any facts to back this up but that
could be why when you see the world
economic forum's plan uh for 2030 it's
that you you'll eat no meat
and you'll just continue to eat these
soy products and there's no protein
there
you know we don't want you increasing
your levels of testosterone we don't
want you going to the gym because we
want all the males out there just to
basically be neutered uh in the corner
and just shut up so we can control
society
good to know that you share the same
opinion um
so you speak about the silent majority
how hard is it for you to go out and say
these things i personally find it very
difficult um i still try to i find it
quite depressing at the same time so i
don't like to have my twitter feed just
full of it um but you have to be brave
and you have to be willing to be fired
you have to be willing to be ostracized
you have to be willing to have your
family not speak to you um so how do you
go about doing that and what advice
would you have for other people who
feel the same way but are afraid to
speak up
well let me uh yeah
so first and foremost with me i i feel a
great sense of responsibility
because i do realize that i'm in a very
unique position
i retired in 2012
at the ripe old age of 38
so i don't need youtube
i don't need a job i don't need money i
don't need any of that stuff i've got
plenty of it
right so i've got that financial freedom
uh not only that i don't have a family
uh well i've got a family i shouldn't
say that but i don't have a wife
uh so i don't and not only that but from
a standpoint of what i do
uh i don't have any investors
i don't have anyone that uh is relying
upon me to a significant degree so i can
be as irresponsible as i want to be
and i've got the
financial wherewithal to weather any
type of storm
so i realize that this
movement if you want to call it that
it needs people who are willing to go
out there and be a lightning rod
and
that don't have to back down to the
vocal minority let's say uh the mob on
social media on twitter or wherever they
they sprout up and uh again i realize
that i'm in a unique position there so
that just gives me a further sense of
responsibility to make sure that i am
standing up and fighting for the
principles that this country was built
on a really western civilization was
built on and really standing up for
freedom liberty and free market
capitalism now as far as the
average individual i understand they are
not in my position by any stretch so
they have to be very cognizant about
what they say i think some of the things
that you can do to move the needle is
just really with your friends family
members co-workers i would start talking
to them about bitcoin
i think one of the you know people
always like to talk about the price
direction of bitcoin where it's going i
think that's the least interesting thing
about it
uh i think that's maybe a way to sync
the hook because a lot of your uh i call
them friend and family member fred's
you know just your typical uh you know
cnn viewer there that you know on your
facebook feed or whatever uh they they
might not get interested in bitcoin if
you start talking to them about the
principles of hayek or or eases or
something like that but if you start
talking oh you know did you see bitcoin
went up by 20
or you know 100 in the last six months
oh really wow
oh man i my pension fund might be you
know might not be there in the future
what is this bitcoin thing i've heard
about it let me let me know more or i
want to understand more so then you
introduce them to
bitcoin but then what hopefully they'll
do is they'll under start to understand
the principles of sound money i think
that's what makes bitcoin very
interesting it's it's the philosophy
behind it and then once they are
introduced to the concept of sound money
then they'll most likely get into
austrian economics and then from there
it's going to lead them straight into
the value of the individual sovereignty
freedom and liberty
and so i think that's a very indirect
way that people can really
affect change in their local community
but i would argue the same thing about
gold
you know maybe that's a conversation
that you can have with some of your
buddies at the bar or some of your you
know girlfriends when you guys are out
is just talking about precious metals uh
because i think that's another way that
they'll go down that rabbit hole if you
will and come to the same conclusions
because it takes them uh and it
introduces them to the value of those
sound money principles that we were
talking about earlier and then they
stumble across the freedom and liberty
movement maybe uh libertarians like ron
paul
or tom woods bob murphy et cetera and
then lastly uh
that's another thing that i do is maybe
just
at an appropriate time
uh send them a video of ron paul
and uh i i i love ron paul for on for a
lot of reasons but what's one of the
great things about him is he's very um
it's tough to hate ron paul
and even if you're someone that's way on
the left your typical bernie sanders or
uh aoc type or someone that watches cnn
constantly
it's it's tough to get mad at ron paul
oh i hate that guy he's he's just uh you
know he's a crazy alt-right uh racist or
misogynist or something like that and so
if you send them some videos of ron paul
talking about the values of freedom and
liberty maybe not some of the hot but
excuse me the hot button issues that
we've been talking about on this video
but maybe some more um
you know benign topics uh just kind of
zooming out and looking at the society
and the principles and why we should
value
freedom over safety and then again let
them kind of
digest that information and hopefully
they'll consume more and three or four
months later you'll talk to them and
they'll say you know what i i really
appreciate you sending me those videos
and in addition to the ron paul videos i
just recently read the road to serfdom
by hayek and you know i want to talk to
you about this i think that's the best
thing that the average person can do
yeah i definitely agree with you um that
the philosophy behind bitcoin for me
personally is the most um exciting thing
the the fact that it does um empower
personal responsibility um individual
freedoms and so on so how did you first
come across bitcoin because obviously i
know you come from the traditional
financial world so how did you come
across bitcoin
well i don't know if i came from the
traditional financial world
i've never taken a finance class in my
life i've never taken an econ class i
almost flunked out of high school uh so
i was just but you you focus more on but
you focus more on on the traditional
side of things i mean like you said you
retired at 38 right so that was
obviously before bitcoin
yeah that was that wasn't by through
investing uh that was oh okay more than
i consume well let's let's point that
out i was producing i'm very very proud
of by the way uh i i didn't get that uh
i didn't get um to a point of being able
to retire financially by buying a you
know a house that went up 10 times in
price or by myself so you need to know
but you need to understand money but you
need to be able to understand money and
understand finance and how the world
works in order to retire at 38 right no
i disagree no tell me
because i was an entrepreneur i i
created stuff that people valued more
than the money in their pocket
and so i was very i i contributed quite
heavily to what i would argue is the
wealth of our society because i was
producing goods and services i was
producing far more uh than i consumed
and when i retired i didn't know what
the fed was i didn't know what the yield
curve was i didn't know really uh
anything i didn't know how dollars were
created i mean i was completely
oblivious to finance but i knew how to
make money i was a very good
entrepreneur and i think uh ironically
enough what the
attributes that make a good entrepreneur
are pretty much the antithesis of what
makes a good investor they're polar
opposites
so when i got into the world of
investing in 2012 because i needed to
invest my own money
or i wanted to
i really had to kind of retrain my brain
uh to to think in a much much much
different way but to answer your your
your basic question there when was i
introduced to bitcoin um boys probably
in
i'd say
2014 maybe
right around that time i was spending a
lot of time in south america so that's
when i first started looking into it and
that's what i did is i looked at the
principles behind it and that's what
always fascinated me the most is how we
could possibly have sound money and what
that would do
to
the overall economy
if we had
a money that allowed free market
capitalism to produce deflation
naturally
i think what just blew my mind was the
fact that you said that you before
bitcoin you retired before you even knew
how money worked i like did not realize
that in the slightest from your videos
and from everything um
so
that takes me on another rabbit hole in
terms of financial literacy because i'm
always banging on about how important
that is um but i guess it's not just the
lack of financial literacy which we need
to improve on but it's also just that
entrepreneurial mindset um and how to
build so how did you learn how to build
then and create something or be an
entrepreneur is that something which
came natural
yeah
yeah it did uh if i for whatever reason
um you know i never set out to be an
entrepreneur i wasn't one of those kids
that said oh i'm gonna be an
entrepreneur i played sports uh i played
ice hockey when i was a kid i played
football i played basketball uh i played
golf play and pretty much every sport
that you could possibly play so i was
very very competitive
um
but i i never thought well i'm just
gonna have my own business i was never
one of those people like a gary
vaynerchuk or something like that mm-hmm
um it's just when i
you know got uh what was i maybe 26 27
or something like that i started a
t-shirt business uh just simply because
the fact that all my buddies were
borrowing my t-shirts
and so i'm like well if they like my
t-shirts maybe i should just make some
and sell them maybe i could make a
little bit of money and this was right
around the you know the time that the
dot-com
this would have been like 98 or
something like that
and so i'm like well maybe i can start
this website thing so i started to do
that that business went south you know i
lost a ton of money with that of course
but that was the uh
that was kind of my entry point and from
there i
did some other jobs and worked for other
people and i did some consulting but
then i kept going back to starting my
own business and uh that's what kind of
just always felt natural uh to me and
that's what really fit my skill set uh
you know
for better or worse i am the worst
employee you could ever have
uh you know i i'm for better
yeah i i obviously i'm not a big fan of
authority and i i'm very independent and
i can be slightly argumentative
if i feel he's a great trait if i feel
so you're wrong uh but i am good at uh
things like problem solving
uh i'm very good at managing people
i like to lead from the front of the
pack and i've always been that way since
i was a little kid
and so these attributes that you really
need as an entrepreneur i think i had
those in spades is this something that i
was very fortunate to be brought up that
way or kind of be hardwired that way
genetically and so
i always kind of fell back on that and i
i was very uh i was very good at it
um now there are a lot of things that
helped me along the way of course uh
with mentors and one of the things that
really helped me the most was reading um
beat the dealer by ed thorpe and it's a
book that i have up on my my bookcase
back here but that's uh i was introduced
to that book way back in
probably 2000 or 2001 in 2002
and i read the market wizards books uh
and i noticed that when i was reading
the original the one with jim rogers
uh a lot of the guys had their start
in blackjack
and i'm like well that's weird why why
and so you go into then you start to
understand how important probabilities
are
when you're a trader or when even if
you're a long-term investor
and then i said okay if i want to be
better at money if i even want to be
better at my business because again back
then i knew nothing about economics or
finance i was just trying to improve my
business yeah or my business ability
i said maybe i should learn this
blackjack thing because it would help
train my brain to think in terms of
probabilities
so i started counting cards and i would
go up to the local indian casino i
remember i was in san francisco in marin
county and i'd go to the local uh indian
casino and on the weekends and i would i
would literally be there eight hours
uh straight
counting cards and uh playing blackjack
and uh i would make very very small bets
so i'd never get kicked out or anything
and but the whole purpose was just to
get my brain to think in those terms
and then uh i did that for probably six
months or so and then i started to apply
those principles to the next business
that i had and just really try to make
it a numbers game and i won't go into
great detail but i think that's one of
the main reasons why that next business
became so successful
and the business after that is the one
where i had really fine-tuned those um
ideas and that skill set along with the
skill set we were talking about earlier
with problem solving and managing people
and being very ambitious that's another
one and self-starting but i was able to
combine all those and then in 2007 i
started a business that was uh from a
financial standpoint was extremely
extremely successful
yeah i think i'm still so fascinated um
by the fact that you just didn't have
that financial literacy and i think your
story's really interesting um
i think i love the fact that
it's it is all about having those skill
sets being um you know it's not just
about having a vision but it's about um
not being agreeable
being um competitive um slightly
aggressive in in some ways um with your
goals um so yeah i think that's really
important i even think it's important
sometimes for women to be aware of those
things um because i don't think those
kind of um traits come naturally um so i
often say you know if women do want to
you know be that ceo or be you know be
more successful whatever it is then
you're going to want to adopt those
those masculine traits at times um so i
think that's interesting um but i want
to talk a little bit actually um about
inflation um i saw a couple of videos
that that you um had posted about it and
i think what's fascinating me right now
is the video that just surfaced and i
think it came out of the uk actually um
and it was sort of saying that um we
didn't economists didn't know
that inflation was going to be like this
um so like how do i know like i'm in my
20s like how do i know that inflation
was going to be awful um after all the
money printing and that by the time they
opened up the economy so
how did how how did they not know did
they know are they lying
what's your take
i think they're just uh ignorant you
know and what happens
yeah i think so what what i've noticed
is
as we're raised as kids we have a
significant degree of common sense
uh the bs meter i think is is very
fine-tuned
and when
people who
are interested in economics or finance
when they go to college and actually
study economics the whole process
i think is really meant to replace
the common sense
with graphs models charts
and what you would expect from uh the
school of keynesian economics uh and
they really need to kind of
brainwash you it's like
remember that scene in zoolander the
original one where ben
where uh will ferrell is trying to
brainwash him and all these little candy
canes are going by the screen here you
see the cartoon where the dog's got his
eyes like the toothpicks in his eyes and
they're trying to brainwash them i think
that's what you have to do to an
individual when they study economics in
college
you have to brainwash them and to a
point where they completely forget
common sense
and they completely rely on these
economic models
that uh might
look good in a textbook but when you
actually apply them into reality
they really don't work
and so
that's what i think they kind of fall
back on because if those models if those
economic models weren't true
you got to take your stereotypical phd
economist
and if those models weren't true
then that would mean their entire career
has been a farce
their college degree is a farce yeah
pretty much everything they've done in
their life now you're dealing with some
extreme cognitive dissonance
uh so
i i think that
those individuals would rather try would
rather rationalize why their models are
not working
as opposed to
actually have an honest discussion with
themselves as to the accuracy of those
models so this perpetuates more and more
and more of these uh
uh predictions let's say
where uh to the person just using common
sense
they come to the conclusion that how
could you not know that uh you've got
the supply of stuff
decreasing substantially because you're
locking everyone in a cage
and then what you're doing is you're
giving these people
trillions of dollars
i use a chart often in my videos and i'm
not sure about the uk but here in the
united states
uh they have a fred chart
which kind of breaks down m2 money
supply and this fred chart shows the
dollars the amount of dollars that are
in checking accounts
of american households in aggregate
total
all right so basically the amount of
dollars that are in checking counts for
the average joe and jane
going into
2020 the number was right around 1.2
trillion
today it's 3.6
trillion dollars
an increase of 2.4 trillion
when your starting point is 1.2 trillion
so how can you expect or how can you
create that many currency units on the
balance sheet of the average american
and reduce the amount of goods and
services produced and expect anything
other than consumer price inflation
it kind of reminds me of that cognitive
dissonance and um being unwilling to
accept where you've gone wrong um given
if you you know built your whole life on
something sort of reminds me of what
we're talking about when we're speaking
about lockdowns um and why people are so
blind to it i think it's sometimes so
hard to accept that everything that the
foundation of society is built on um is
a lie or is inherently
slightly corrupt well that gets very
that gets very deep because you've got
someone's world view that believes we
should have more government
that's their basic world view that's
their religion and then you've got the
other group that maybe they believe uh
that we should have smaller government
but those are kind of or we should have
more power in the private sector and
then the other group believes we should
have more power in the public sector
well you you can't
have the public sec or you can't come to
the conclusion
that the public sector is lying to you
about mandates if they're lying to you
about the medicine if they're lying to
you about anything you you can't
accept that because if you accept that
to be true
then it completely collapses
the your entire belief system
because if the government is lying to
you about that
then what are they lying to you about in
terms of welfare what are they lying to
you about in terms of let's call it
racial or social justice
right what are they what else are they
lying to you about and then you start
going down that rabbit hole and you come
to the conclusion that wait a minute i
was wrong
we we don't need bigger government we
need smaller government
and i think they're just really avoiding
going down that rabbit hole because they
would rather
you know ignorance is bliss
they would rather live their life in a
state of ignorance and be able to sleep
at night
just
telling themselves that their belief
system
is uh is correct morally
instead of
you know taking the red pill if you will
yes i'm gonna say discovering those
uncomfortable truths
yeah i think it really i know it's so
cringy and um stereotypical but the
matrix what a great film um red pill
versus blue pill
and actually the the final one that is
coming out uh i think in a few weeks
actually so what uh what an iconic
moment for it to be
released i think i think it's
interesting on a lot of different levels
remember when when neo took the red pill
and he woke up in that capsule of gel
because he was able to see reality
and all of the other human beings that
were there trapped in that reality and
they thought that they were living just
a normal life but they didn't realize
that the machines had them and batteries
yeah in this capsule of gel just keeping
them alive
and i would look at that in terms of
what's happening right now in australia
and i say this and
people may say that's an extreme but
that my point is at a certain
time
you have to ask yourself if being alive
is the same thing as living
you see those people in the capsule in
the matrix they were alive
they weren't living
and it's just like the people right now
in australia they might be alive but
they're not living the government is
stealing years away from them
ironically all in the name of safety and
the greater good
yeah i think you speak so eloquently
about it and i really appreciate um you
speaking out about it and coming on the
show and really just going through all
of this because it's it's so
um it's awful um for me it's so
unethical um i've been talking a lot
about it on um across my social media
stories and just unethical is the only
word that i that i can really come to um
i don't think there's anything okay
about it um and you're right stealing
people's time like i feel that way i
feel i'm in my 20s i feel like my time
is literally being stolen um but it's
okay i will um i i i have other ways to
live a great life
they have to they they can't just look
at lives lost they have to look at years
lost so let's look at australia again as
an example the average age of someone
there that has passed away from the
survey sickness is 82 years old
so let's just give all those 82 year
olds the benefit of the doubt and say
they would have lived another five years
which is highly unlikely highly unlikely
yes
they did let's say they have zero or
they they have a thousand uh deaths
something like that and you compare that
to florida
a country of relatively the same
population they have let's say 50 000
uh deaths there you say well my gosh
australia is doing so much better of a
job well let's just say that they would
have had the same freedom they would
have they would have not have gone down
the path of turning their country into a
totalitarian police state well then they
would have had an additional 50 000
deaths let's just use round numbers okay
well what you're doing there is you're
saying that those five years for the 82
year old you're gonna have another 50
000 of those okay so how many years does
that equate to that's 250 000 years
okay so you'd have an additional 250 000
years loss we say george that's
absolutely catastrophic that's horrible
we can't have that
okay but look at your alternatives
right as thomas soul teaches us well
there are no solutions there are only
trade-offs
right so we've got that uh as our
starting point but what do you have to
do to save those 250 000 years by the
way from old people well you have to
lock everyone in a cage you have to
steal years away from the young people
so let's just say that there's a
population of 25 million and half of
those people 12.5 have been in lockdown
for
12.5 million have been in a lockdown for
one year
well now what you've done
is you've taken
12.5 million years
away from your population
your young population by the way just to
give 250 000 years
to your the population that's over 80
years old
you see how does that make any sense at
all
it doesn't whatsoever so if you're truly
concerned about saving years which is
basically saving lives then you should
completely abolish all of these
lockdowns and you should take a stance
that florida has taken and texas has
taken among many other states where you
let people make their own decisions
yeah i think it's um phenomenal when you
put it like that i'm actually in florida
right now um and
loving it and it just blows my mind
because um the uk is
potentially looking at going into
another lockdown europe of course have
we spoken about and i think actually
what's the creepiest thing is and i was
thinking about this the other day um
everybody's out here and they're smiling
everybody's happy there's no mask
there's no social distance and everyone
is just happy and then i'm thinking
about everything that's going on in
europe and i'm like
then is that even necessary like how can
we survive and be okay here
yet where i'm from in europe it's
getting worse and the riots are starting
the fires are starting you know when you
weigh those things up and really the
science technically should be the same
everywhere the science should be the
same everywhere the medicine is the same
the the disease is the same um and yet
totally different responses it just it's
really heartbreaking you know um but
that's because one group of people are
actually living
and the other group of people are just
alive exactly um but george i want to
thank you so much i really do appreciate
you coming on and going through all of
this with us um do you have any last
words what are you working on right now
where can people follow you and tell us
your twitter and youtube yeah they can
just google george gammon it's just
typical uh spelling of george last names
g-a-m-m-o-n
um i'm probably
probably too many things will pop up for
my own good there we go
twitter all the social media and all the
youtube channels
yeah guys go follow george um and i
think we just need to have more of these
conversations and hopefully we can um i
don't like to use this expression but
wake more people up george thank you so
much for coming on thank you everyone
for watching and we'll see you all next
week bye
[Applause]
[Music]